today we will be redrawing the new cgi
dragon ball movie in traditional 2d
styles the new super dragon ball super
movie dragon ball super super hero will
be hitting our screens this summer and
apart from looking like a really
interesting development for underused
characters like piccolo goten trunks and
gohan it's also the very first dragon
ball film to be produced entirely using
computer generated visuals save for
perhaps some small moments in the recent
films traditionally dragon ball has
existed only in two dimensions with the
games being the only venture into the 3d
arena and while my heart will always
belong to traditional hand-drawn 2d
animation this new film looks great with
some really interesting approaches taken
to help bridge the divide between 3d and
2d audiences with all of that said
however it did get us thinking all of
these new trailers action sequences and
characters coloring our screens were
wonderful but we did wonder what might
this movie look like if it were created
using traditional 2d visuals instead of
cgi it's an interesting question for
sure but there is a problem what style
would we draw it in over the last 30
years dragon ball's visual identity has
changed more times than i can count with
a host of different artists giving their
own unique and iconic spins on the
franchise and that's when we had an idea
what if instead of focusing on just one
style we did all of them what if we
select a bunch of images from the
trailers gave each of them to a
different artist on the tnm team to
tackle with each drawing needing to be
drawn in a different iconic dragon ball
style from classic toriyama all the way
to shintani's dragon ball super broly
designs sounds like a fun video right
well no
god this was a nightmare and to make
matters worse i think i've developed
ptsd from a particular drawing i'll let
you guys figure out which one that was
so let's dive in
the first image up in the chopping block
to draw is this close-up from the first
trailer with sun gohan a simple enough
one to start things off with and the
first artist to draw is
[Music]
me oh joy and i have to redraw this
picture of gohan in the style of
dragon ball super
let's try it out alright so this one was
one of the easier drawings i did for the
video and to be honest i was really
happy with how it turned out there were
virtually no changes i needed to make to
the anatomy of the original cgi image
and so really the only alterations that
needed to be made were on a stylistic
front with this being the most modern of
the current styles of the series i was
excited to see how this one would turn
out in the end and maybe in some
alternate timeline the movie would have
followed in the visual style of the
broly film but who knows for now this is
as close as we're gonna get one of the
most important parts of the broly film
style has to be its line art in order to
achieve this varied weight look the film
did i had to do my line art with a fancy
one pixel thick brush with zero aliasing
if you don't know what that is just know
that it looks like ass until a final
filter is applied speaking of which
special thanks to friend of the channel
mix who helped apply this filter without
him this simply just wouldn't have
worked so let's take a look at the
finished product one two three
awesome looks legit thanks once again to
mix for helping with some of the images
in this video and so the next image we
have to draw is
oh this is an interesting one the new
character gamma number one and which one
of us will have to tackle this
editor sand and the style
classic toriyama to tell you the truth
this was the image i was most excited to
see produced not just because i'm a fan
of the design or toriyama specifically
but because this was the only image that
was drawn and produced using physical
non-digital traditional manga tools in
this video editor stan is an enthusiast
for manga production and quote does not
recommend buying the screen tones or any
such products unless they are either
available in your country or you are
very keen on becoming a professional and
spending a lot of money though if you
are interested there is apparently this
really interesting video with the
legendary naoki urasawa demonstrating
how to add screen tones to produce this
editor san needed to margin the page
accordingly sketch the layout ink the
final piece using the traditional tools
and finally physically cut out his own
screen tones to add to the finished
product i think my favorite aspect of
this whole process that editor-san is
undergoing is pretty much what i like
about this video it's taking a peek back
into the past using different styles on
modern material physical manga creation
is becoming more and more outdated as
time matches on and heck toriyama
himself even started to draw digitally
over a decade ago and it makes sense the
materials can be expensive and digital
is far more convenient still though just
looking at this there's something so
interesting and different about this
approach and one i was very interested
in being honored in this video
fantastic work editors and that's one
fantastic looking two-page spread next
up our third image and on this list is
the lovely cgi close-up of vegeta
and our next artist to tackle it is
trev who will have to redraw it in the
style of
modern tarayoshi yamamuro otherwise
known as dragon ball super's art style
tadayoshi yamamuro caught his teeth with
early dragon ball before going on to
become one of the most iconic animators
and character designers for the final
arc of z as well as all of dragon ball
super however he is not present in this
film as far as we are aware the
character designer and animation
director for dragon ball super superhero
is an individual called chikashi kubota
most will know him as one punch man's
character designer but he's also a huge
dragon ball fan having worked in dragon
ball super broly and even releasing his
own dragon ball art book it's obvious he
knows his dragon ball interestingly his
role in this film will be to touch up
the 3d models with 2d draw overs those
with a keen eye while watching battle of
gods and resurrection f saw that in
those cgi sequences things didn't look
quite right as dragon ball doesn't quite
work in 3d without changing up the model
dramatically and so in superhero thanks
to 2d corrections to the faces we get
stunning shots of goku and other
characters in the trailers that while
primarily still cg can remain true to
the design philosophy of dragon ball but
overall this drawing itself was no
challenge for trev and so it's
interesting getting to see what this
might have looked like had it been in
dragon ball super back in the day good
work trev and next up is this lovely
image of piccolo so who's going to be
drawing this lovely fella
me okay and the style is
toyotaro
okay
uh this is gonna be tough and tough it
most definitely was i've had my
criticisms of toyotaro in the past but
he actually draws namekians and piccolo
very very well and i'm nowhere near as
talented as he is regrettably and if
that wasn't all this cgi image i'm
attempting to redraw presented its own
challenges i've mentioned a few times in
this video that when you translate a 2d
design like dragon ball into 3d space it
doesn't always work too smoothly and for
whatever reason the angle piccolo's head
was in this image i just could not get
right eventually however thanks to some
help from trev i was able to land on
something that we were all happy with i
tried to emulate toyotaro's detail in
the arms as well as implement the
typical shapes he uses for the facial
features and clothing folds in the end i
was really happy with how it turned out
and when you compared with the original
i think the difference is quite stark
and while this one was tough it wasn't
anywhere near as hard as things got for
me in this video but more on that later
next image up for the redraw is oh this
is a nice upshot of gohan in his super
saiyan form and redrawing this image
will be trev again and in the style of
classic tadayoshi yamamuro or as many of
you might be familiar with the style
that defined much of the buu saga this
style is trev's bread and butter and
while he could emulate this style in his
sleep much the same way i had difficulty
with the previous image trev 2 had
difficulty translating this 3d angle
into dragon ball's 2d philosophy and
there's an interesting reason as to why
the issue with dragon ball in 3d is that
toriyama's designs don't actually make
sense in three-dimensional space so what
do i mean when i say that well consider
goku's hair for example in 2d it
functions much like mickey mouse's ears
in that it just flips rather than
rotating in 3d this couldn't work
similarly and this is where this angle
has given us trouble the manner with
which various characters faces compress
at three-quarter angles doesn't really
make sense in 2d when akira toriyama
designed these characters he did so
without consideration for what they
would look like in three-dimensional
space naturally this isn't to say that
it's impossible to get around these
issues though and there are a few ways
of doing it when you look at some of the
older video game 3d models they were
true to 3d models and as a result the
faces at angles didn't really look great
or at least not in the way toriyama
would have drawn them and so to remedy
this problem artists would shift and
warp the faces at certain angles to
create a better likeness to the original
designs effectively breaking their 3d
models momentarily in the process while
dragon ball fighterz was one of the most
recent examples of one that does this in
real time one of the most amazing
instances that's perfected pretty much
every element is dragon ball legends
intro video it's all a bit fast and hard
to read since it's a short op but if you
look at all the elements it's kind of
incredible but with that said i think
trev managed to find a nice happy medium
with this angle compressing the face to
create a faithful adaptation of this
image true to the design philosophy of
the time and of course true to the
classic teddy yoshi yamamuro from the
buu saga amazing work trev next up this
monstrosity and i had to draw it in the
style of masaki sato uh for those of you
that might not be familiar with masaki
sato he's the man behind some of my
favorite illustrations from the original
run of dragon ball and dragon ball z on
tv he's behind some of the most iconic
scenes in the series not limited to goku
vs piccolo krillin throwing the spirit
bomb of vegeta and of course a little
scene you might have heard of goku's
first transformation into super saiyan
to name but a few he's featured in
various films and overall is known for
his rugged and detailed approach and it
made me want to unalive myself everyone
else that worked on this video spent
maybe a few hours at most in a single
drawing this one took me three days and
is the reason why this video is as late
as it was and was it worth it nothing
was worth this everything about this was
working against me the angle his face
was at was bizarre not quite looking
right at you not quite looking up not
quite three quarters an angle made for
3d and designed to destroy my spirit it
was the pose was also unconventional and
i had to use every morsel of willpower i
had to not break my ipad that i was
drawing on into but really the most
difficult aspect of this was the design
itself and adapting it the film uses
designs that are quite modern toriyama
in approach from the rounder shapes all
the way to the soft shading which made
even the shading of this drawing a
difficult enterprise to figure out as
masaki sado's style is so different to
the philosophy on display here with its
being angular detailed and layered and
even its shading even with the help of
all the other artists in this video this
one broke my spirit i managed to
eventually get to something where we
were all happy but in the end this image
unequivocally defeated me
but that seems sort of depressing to end
on a high note here's trevory drawing
goku in a style of yuya takahashi making
it look insultingly easy it even
demonstrates how goku's hair when not
touched up manually doesn't really look
quite right in 3d if this video has
taught me anything it's that i am
nowhere near as talented as the artists
that have worked on this film and indeed
the prior incarnations of the series
these are all people that deserve our
respect and i'm excited to see what this
new dragon ball super movie has in store
for us this summer taking on toriyama's
style in 3d is no easy feat so seeing
how staff are attempting to overcome the
nuances required to make it look right
is a fascinating exercise and one i'm
excited to see once the movie's out with
that said i'm always looking for reasons
to keep drawing and making these videos
and so since a new trailer just dropped
with tons of interesting new shots and
angles i figured a part 2 to this video
is in order and so next week you will
get more redraws from this film from me
and the team but we're going to need
some help with this and this is where
you come in we need suggestions so in
order for you to be in with a chance for
your suggestions to make it into next
week's video all you gotta do is
subscribe to this channel follow me on
twitter totally not mark and share your
suggestions using the hashtag dbs redraw
just make sure it's a still from the
trailer of dragon ball super superhero i
look forward to seeing your suggestions
and i'll see you all next week thank you
so much for watching
[Music]
you